let's follow up about the Montana story
last week we talked about Montana
Republican candidate for the US House of
Representatives Greg John Forte who
body-slammed a reporter from The
Guardian at a campaign event the day
before the election charged with
misdemeanor assault by the local
sheriff's office and three major
newspapers pulled their endorsement of
Jenn Forte here's just a reminder about
what that sounded like you just bodyslam
me it broke my glasses get the hell out
of here yeah you'd like me to get the
Honda thread also like to call the
police yeah by the way the sheriff whose
department had to charge Jenn Forte
donated to his campaign so of course he
wasn't handcuffed because of that and
because he's an incredibly wealthy white
politician imagine if this had been a 22
year old black man suspected of body
slamming a reporter from The Guardian
would have been dealt with differently
that I can assure you anyway Jen for
taste campaign released a bogus
statement responding to the incident
saying that this was a liberal
journalist who was you know in there
aggressively asking questions everybody
in the room including Fox News reporters
said that that was absolutely not the
way it happened the way that the actual
reporter said it happened is the real
story but like I said voting day for
this congressional election was the day
after the incident and Greg John forté
is no longer a candidate Pat he is now
US representative elect for Montana's
at-large congressional district winning
with fifty point one percent of the vote
a six percentage point victory over the
Democratic opponent this shouldn't
surprise us for any number of reasons
number one John forté is a
fundamentalist Christian and
creationists Republican in Montana and
he was already ahead in the polls when
he went into election day despite the
body-slamming incident number two it was
after all the day before the election
and most people had probably already
made up their minds pretty firmly about
who they were gonna vote for and
whatever reporting there was about the
incident many voters were not going to
watch more news before voting but I
actually don't think that it's as if
most voters didn't hear about it it was
national news so importantly and maybe
most it most importantly I would say
many Republicans right now are just not
going to be deterred by this type of
violent behavior from a politician this
is an implicit a tacit endorsement of
being violent against reporters as long
as you check the right boxes in terms of
by the way they claim to hate identity
politics they love it when you're
talking about this particular identity
the violence is acceptable at this point
yeah I think there are some Republicans
who voted for Gian Forte despite the
fact that he body-slammed a reporter
yeah and there are also Republicans who
actually kind of enjoyed that behavior
you have Rush Limbaugh saying that John
forté is a manly and studly guy and he
body-slammed a reporter who is a pajama
boy millennial yep and then a live
caller called in to his program and said
that his chances of voting for
Republicans would grow exponentially if
more of them did this yet there's no
doubt about it and thanks to Donald
Trump and the 2017 Republican Party in
the u.s. this is the type of thing that
we are seeing is increasingly acceptable
everyday and by the way what what
countries is this reminiscent of where
journalists are attacked it's I mean
I've just read an arc anomic sand you
should see how journalists who want to
report on the drug on drug crimes in
parts of Mexico are dealt with they're
killed and so are their families we know
about what happens with adversarial
journalists in oh I don't know Vladimir
Putin's Russia in the u.s. it is now
acceptable for a billionaire politician
to physically attack a newspaper
reporter this is a historically
dangerous track that we are on and the
the attitude that we're seeing from
Republican voters is as much a part of
the problem as gen Forte's actions and I
thought the Republicans were the law &
order types constitutionalists
apparently that doesn't apply when
you're going against reporters and able
to undermine freedom of the press yeah
but it was an attack dog liberal yellow
journalist Pat all the law and order
goes out the window when that's the case
and the guy is clearly unstable too
there's
no break in between when he tells the
reporter to go speak to Shane the guy
who works for him and yeah it's a wreck
that makes you think that he has
something going oh there's something
going on yeah that's the understatement
of the century this guy's got something
going on all right a lot of discussions
of about this on reddit david pakman.com
slash re d di t today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30 day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s